A familiar question rocks the Marvel Cinematic
Universe: "What If?"
In episode one of the new animated series,
the question gets applied to Agent Carter.
Specifically: What If Peggy Carter stayed
in the room when Steve Rogers became Captain
America?
"Wouldn't you be more comfortable in the booth?"
"No, I'd prefer to stay."
The answer, it seems, is chaos.
During Hydra's attack on the Super Soldier
program by undercover members of the State
Department, Peggy's slightly altered proximity
to the super-soldier serum changes the whole
game.
Steve is shot before he can receive the life-altering
injections and lies bleeding on the floor,
while the capable Carter drops the saboteur
and tells Steve to stay put.
Short on time and bereft of other options,
Carter climbs into the transformation chamber
and gets pumped full of the serum herself.
She emerges transformed, a towering goliath
of proper British strength.
She receives a shield all her own adorned
with the Union Jack, and almost immediately
starts beating her alternate universe American
counterpart at the "winning World War II"
game, nabbing the Tesseract from Arnim Zola
without much muss or fuss.
Steve rehabilitates and, with the help of
Howard Stark's engineering prowess, starts
piloting a suit of Hydra Stomper armor, powered
by the Allies' recently acquired Tesseract.
Newly outfitted in a plate-armored mech suit,
powered by an Infinity Stone and an insatiable
patriotic go-get-em attitude, Steve Rogers
enters the fray and joins Captain Carter on
the battlefield.
"Let's hear it for Captain Carter."
But the fascist-smashing good times can't
last forever, and Captain Carter finds herself
at her lowest point right around the end of
the story's second act.
During "Operation: Where Eagles Dare," Steve
is apparently killed in action thanks to a
stash of dynamite hidden on a Hydra train.
Peggy interrogates an imprisoned Arnim Zola,
learning that the Red Skull is planning to
bust out an interdimensional champion at Castle
Krake in the Black Forest.
Accompanied by the Howling Commandos, Howard
Stark, and Bucky Barnes, Cap invades the castle.
Inside of Castle Krake, our heroes discover
that the Red Skull has captured Rogers, the
Hydra Stomper armor, and the Tesseract that
was inside it.
He opens a portal, summoning a Lovecraftian
horror from beyond the veil of existence to
bring about Hydra's reign of terror.
The terrible beastie has more than a little
in common with the classic Marvel monster
Shuma-Gorath.
But as has often been said, he who lives by
the unspeakable alien abomination must also
die by the unspeakable alien abomination.
And so the Red Skull gets smeared into a Red
Paste, hoisted by his own extradimensional
tentacle.
Afterward, Stark does like a good sci-fi super
scientist is supposed to do and hits some
buttons frantically, trying to reverse the
polarity hard enough to make the rapidly-expanding
squid bits go back to where they came from,
but to no avail.
Steve Rogers, now rescued and back in his
jury rigged, patch-job-powered armor, runs
out of juice before he can make much of an
impact.
The only solution to the tentacle problem
is for Captain Carter to personally shove
the eldritch horror back from whence it came.
She disappears into the unknown, promising
Steve a dance on her way out.
Everything fades to black.
Almost 70 years later, Carter returns, flanked
by cuts of jumbo squid, out of a Cosmic Cube-induced
portal at what looks like the Joint Dark Energy
Mission Facility in the Mojave Desert from
2012's "Avengers."
A super soldier, plucked from history, stands
ripe with promise of becoming the hero of
a new era.
It's all terribly familiar.
So what did we learn here today?
A lot is implied by the universe presented
in the first episode of "What If...?"
First off, Howard Stark was capable of coming
up with an Iron Man suit capable of harnessing
the power of the Tesseract, potentially shifting
the course of human civilization.
But the really intriguing question that the
episode leaves open is, "What would a world
without Peggy Carter look like?"
We know that Agent Carter was instrumental
in the creation of S.H.I.E.L.D. during the
20th century of the MCU proper -- an organization
that itself became an unknowing incubation
chamber for Hydra.
The Dark Energy lab seen at the end of the
episode looks less well-manned than the one
from "Avengers."
Maybe it's a coincidence, or maybe Hydra got
more of a foothold without Peggy around to
keep an eye on things.
We don't see anything about the world outside
the lab circa 2012, but it's hard to imagine
that things went better without the supervision
of one of the Allied Forces' most legendary
agents, even with Bucky and Steve set up to
stand in for her.
Without Bucky to use as their Vibranium-armed
super soldier, Hydra wouldn't have had their
go-to agent available to kill Howard and Maria
Stark on December 16, 1991.
"Wow, thanks, you almost ripped my arm off."
Without his father's absence, Tony might not
have had any reason to rise to the occasion
and learn how to take the wheel of his old
man's company.
What's worse, with Iron Man-adjacent technology
entering into play some six decades early,
a whole new set of potential travesties would
be lined up.
Assuming that the U.S.
Government retained the rights to the invention,
the course of manned warfare on Earth would
have drastically changed, and an international
race to create powered suits would have likely
kicked off during the Cold War, opening the
door to mid-20th century versions of the Crimson
Dynamo, Titanium Man, and Iron Monger.
Then again, maybe Howard Stark held onto the
technology for himself and went into business
selling Iron Man suits, powered by Tesseract
energy, with the Cube no longer destined to
sit in mothballs for decades in the wake of
his up-close comprehension of its potential.
Maybe Howard used the Tesseract and its physics-defying
abilities to finally realize that new element
that he'd had his eye on but couldn't create
thanks to the limitations of his day.
Dozens of conflicts across U.S. history would
suddenly be shifted thanks to the presence
of legions of Iron Men.
Perhaps Howard refuses to relinquish the Tesseract
to Project P.E.G.A.S.U.S., halting the creation
of Captain Marvel and dooming the Earth upon
the arrival of Thanos.
The implications are countless… or maybe
we're just really overthinking a cartoon,
and everything ends up more or less the same.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.